hey Chris have you heard of the Titanic
yes you're going down
do you know what I smell an ass whuppin
ass whuppin ass well then may the best
human win I have a horrible memory my
memory is also bad but the fact that she
flipped it so quickly makes me think
it's me yeah all right
good building what can it mine you're
not even in my line of sight all right
let's take a look yeah she won oh yeah
oh no way did you get it exactly when I
get really excited about something I get
super focused where I like will be
working on a project and not moving for
like 12 hours I'll think you know what
pouty
me I will lay that for up back oh yeah a
budget Queen 46 seconds that's pretty
good 38 seconds faster than Eli say mean
yeah I think you probably smell better
every day what smells like potato chips
oh I mean it smells like pine - lavender
it just smells like a car freshener
grapefruit god I literally have no idea
what this is like pencils just like yarn
it's gonna be part of the competition
cuz I will crush her
hey hey how's it going
oh I really like your shoes I just kind
of like laugh a lot and like bat my
eyelashes so you know what we want no
time for you so I'm just doing my thing
you know reading a book and I look over
and she sees me I look down just go back
to me maybe you felt like a little bite
in like I'll give it to him I don't want
ladies look am I gonna brag about
winning yes yes in all honesty I'm not
surprised at all and I'm happy that you
won
Chris I feel like I'm supposed to be
surprised but deep down inside it's all
stuff that I feel like I knew women were
good at it's just that we're not known
for being good at those things
but women secretly run the world and it
needs to be known did you notice
anything unusual about the cruise today
I noticed that it was all women and I
loved that
and we from a lot of film sets that's
sorority and we all need to see more
women doing really amazing thing
so what's your name is tho and that's
when you run